[Musique]
Dès que j'ai reçu, j'étais en fait sur un
appel professionnel, donc cela interrompait mon
argent, alors j'ai immédiatement appuyé sur le X et je
m'en suis débarrassé, mais je pense que c'était
nécessaire, absolument pas,
cela pourrait être nécessaire si nous avons une
urgence juste moi  Je ne veux pas être
réveillé au milieu de la nuit avec des
tweets
[Musique]
Je suis vraiment préoccupé par l'expansion
des pouvoirs présidentiels et cela fait
longtemps que j'ai vu que cela s'est
considérablement élargi au cours des 20 dernières années  ans
et cela me préoccupe vraiment parce qu'en tant que
citoyen, j'apprécie vraiment notre
gouvernement, nos freins et contrepoids, je
pense que c'est très important